hey 42 here if you've ever watched lord
of the rings and found yourself
strangely reminded of harry potter you
either have a thing for wizards or
you've unwittingly cottoned on to the
fact that
they're basically the same story frodo
baggins and harry potter both start out
living stable but unfulfilling lives
then each finds himself on a sudden and
unexpected journey full of adventure
peril and challenges
after overcoming numerous obstacles both
characters have to win one final battle
that tests their resolve before they
return to real life forever changed by
their experiences
if you've been living at the bottom of a
well and you don't know who harry potter
or frodo baggins are don't worry
this same story pattern appears in a
genuinely staggering number of books
films tv shows and even computer games
you could say that it's the story within
all stories
a basic template you already know
backwards because
you've seen it a thousand times before
in fact this story structure is so
ubiquitous some people believe it's
literally hardwired into our brains
but more on that later as well as
popular culture this narrative structure
is repeated across myths legends and
stories from across the world and
throughout time and we know about it
mainly thanks to a guy called joseph
campbell
campbell was a professor of literature
and one of the world's leading experts
on mythology
after studying thousands of stories and
tales from all over the world
he noticed a recurring theme that went a
little something like this
a hero goes on an adventure
meets challenges and learns lessons
uses those lessons to win a major
victory
and claim some form of reward
then returns home with said reward
forever transformed
campbell calls this
the mono myth or as it's become more
commonly known the hero's journey
according to campbell the hero's journey
can be broken into three main parts
in stage one the departure the hero
lives in the ordinary world comfortable
enough but generally unsatisfied
something's missing from his life or he
has a sense that something needs to
change but he doesn't know what
but then he receives a call to adventure
something in his life changes and he has
to decide
what to do about it
often the hero refuses to call it first
and tries to hold on to the safety of
his comfortable world
but then someone usually a mentor or
wise person of some sort
helps him to see the need to change and
convinces him to follow that call to
adventure
at this point the hero makes the
decision to go ahead
what campbell calls crossing the
threshold and
the journey begins
in the matrix neo is a computer
programmer by day and hacker by night he
hates his job and feels a general
dissatisfaction with the world that he
can't quite put his finger on
he's searching for something
then he receives a message on his
computer to follow the white rabbit
this is his call to adventure he meets
trinity and she tells him about the
matrix
but when the time comes to escape from
the agents and join morpheus
neo loses faith and gives up
he refuses to call
later he meets morpheus the wise mentor
in person it's morpheus who convinces
him the story about the matrix is true
through the cunning use of vibrant
coloured pills at the start of the lord
of the rings we meet frodo living a
peaceful life in the shire but things
change unexpectedly when he inherits his
uncle bilbo baggins possessions
including a mysterious ring gandalf
discovers that the ring is in fact
the one ring fashioned by the dark lord
sauron and he tells frodo to leave the
shire and take the ring to the elves in
rivendell
this is frodo's call to adventure but
initially he says no he's never left the
shire before and he's afraid he refuses
to call
eventually gandalf his wise mentor
convinces him he's the only person who
can complete the quest and frodo
eventually accepts
of course by the time he meets his first
orc he's cursing wizards and their
seductive beards
but that's all part of the journey
specifically stage two the initiation
in the initiation stage the hero is
totally outside his comfort zone he's
basically in a whole new world which
campbell called the special world
because everything feels different
perhaps even alien
the hero faces a series of tasks and
challenges that become increasingly
difficult
he often has some small wins but also
gets knocked back
so he's forced to learn lessons both
about the world and himself
in movies you often know the heroes
enters the initiation stage because
you're suddenly watching some kind of
montage of him training or doing karate
kicks on top of wooden posts on the
beach at sunset
eventually the hero meets a major
challenge or has to fight an enemy who
would have been beyond his abilities at
the start of the journey but with the
lessons he's learnt he's able to win the
battle and claim the prize
that prize could be something physical
like a treasure but more often it's some
kind of new understanding or wisdom that
makes the hero a more complete person
in harry potter the initiation stage is
basically everything that happens after
we get to hogwarts and before harry
fights volder sorry
he who must not be named
in star wars this stage starts when luke
leaves his home and enters the space
port of moss eisley with obi-wan kenobi
and ends once luke has destroyed the
death star of course it also includes
the part where luke has the hots for his
sister
but that bit's fairly unique
the final stage of the hero journey is
the return
the hero has accomplished something
extraordinary and it's time for him to
get back to reality taking his reward
with him as he re-enters normal life he
realizes how much his experiences have
changed him and he sees life and himself
in a completely new way
sometimes the hero has changed so much
he's unable to return to the life he
once lived like in lord of the rings
when frodo finds himself
unable to settle back into life at the
shire
but other times the hero has found what
was missing at the start of the story
and rejoins the world as a happier more
complete person
like in the matrix
when neo fulfilled the prophecy found
love with a woman who wears lots of
leather and becomes about as cool as
it's possible for a human being to be
whilst wearing a trench coat
joseph campbell published his ideas
about the hero's journey in his 1949
book the hero with a thousand faces
which has been popular in american
literary studies and writing programs
since at least the 70s george lucas for
example used the hero's journey as the
foundation for star wars and hollywood's
screenwriting guru christopher vogler
used it to put together his best-selling
bible for scriptwriters the writer's
journey
but
joseph campbell and his books
aren't the reason the hero journey is
found in almost every story you know
after all tolkien started writing lord
of the rings before the hero of a
thousand faces was even published a
christmas carol by charles dickens was
published in 1843
the epic poem the odyssey basically the
definition of the hero's journey
goes back thousands of years in fact the
monomyth structure shows up in stories
as far back as we have stories
maybe even before yoda was born
what campbell and his fellow researchers
discovered
was that stories with almost identical
themes and symbols have popped up all
over the world in totally different
cultures separated by different
languages distance and time
campbell believes this is because the
hero's journey
is common to all people
a part of the human psyche that's built
into our minds from birth
like legendary swiss psychologist carl
jung who was also deeply interested in
the symbolism of human stories
campbell believed the hero's journey
emerged from a kind of collective
unconscious
we all have a personal unconscious
that's made up of our beliefs
assumptions and biases that's largely
responsible for the way we behave and
the decisions we make
but young believed we also have a
collective unconscious that contains
cognitive structures that have evolved
in our species over the course of human
history
if the stuff in our personal unconscious
is partly what defines us as individuals
our collective unconscious is partly
what defines us as human
and campbell believed this is where the
hero journey lives it's what young and
campbell called an archetype a type of
psychological structure that we're
essentially born with
we can't examine these archetypes
consciously
but since they're a part of who we are
at a fundamental level
we can't help but express them
which is why they keep showing up in
human stories myths and legends
stories are a fundamental part of our
universal human culture
and they're often used as a tool to
teach important lessons and ideas young
believed telling stories gives us an
avenue to explore some of the
darker corners of our unconscious minds
allowing us to confront our fears or
deal with trauma
the hero's journey essentially tells the
story of this process
it uses metaphor to describe how a
person the hero in his own story
realizes that something's wrong with his
life
perhaps he's unhappy in a relationship
maybe he's lost his job or is facing
serious illness we all come up against
these kinds of challenges sooner or
later these calls to adventure if you
like
most of the time we don't want to change
at least not at first
change is difficult and scary
so we refuse to call but eventually
we're convinced that something needs to
shift
so we make the commitment
and cross the threshold
in stories the hero at this point
usually enters a forest or heads out to
sea or ventures into the mountains it's
all unknown territory that feels full of
danger
in real life this usually involves doing
something new and challenging
it could be just joining a gym and
starting exercise
it could be looking for a new job or
learning a new skill
whatever it is we go through multiple
trials and challenges that test our
commitment
eventually though
there's one final test where we face our
demons
or what campbell called are dragons
and confront what's been holding us back
or sabotaging us in work or life
if we manage to slay our dragon whatever
form it takes we claim the reward which
is a greater understanding of ourselves
and who we need to be to be fitter
happier and more productive
finally comes the return where we take
this newfound understanding of ourselves
and turn it into action that makes a
difference in our life
this can be even more difficult than the
ordeal itself
but doing this successfully is what
brings us to the end of our hero's
journey
we may not have crawled through mordor
and thrown a ring into the heart of
mount doom but we did discover something
new about ourselves and what makes us
tick
campbell believed that every person can
go through many of these hero journeys
in their lifetimes
each time understanding themselves a
little better and becoming more
committed to their own happiness
it's what he called following your bliss
and he suggested that everyone can find
at least one example in their lives
of a time when they had to change to
overcome adversity and learn something
new about themselves in the process
campbell's theories haven't been popular
with everyone some folklorists
apparently that's a real job
believe campbell wasn't scientific
enough in his research and that
confirmation bias led him to choose
stories that naturally conforms to his
thinking
and of course
they may be right but the next time you
spend a night binging on netflix
watch out for the classic hero's journey
pattern it might just be that joseph
campbell was onto something
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us it's a wild and
witty journey for a thousand years of
unexpected roman history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you